hi there steve kaufman i have breaking
news breaking news you know how on tv
they always have breaking news and of
course it's something you already knew
it's not breaking it's nothing
particularly
uh breaking
uh but the breaking news that i want to
talk about today is that
to be successful as a language learner
you have to be active you have to be
active if you want to get into shape you
have to be active you have to either go
to the gym or you have to run or you
have to play a lot of sports you have to
be active you don't necessarily have to
know how the body works you don't have
to have that sort of kind of
information about the whys you just have
to be active you go to the gym and
there's equipment there and you use it
some people may require a coach to sort
of set out a program for them or some
people just go there and
do something because if you're active
you're going to get healthy
and the same is true in language
learning i think this is
so important now in order to be active
you have to do things that you enjoy
doing
or at least that you are motivated to do
one way or another and varying things is
one way to ensure you stay active if you
go to the gym and always use the same
equipment that's not going to be as
effective if you go there and use a
variety of different you know
lat machine or
you know treadmill or if you vary things
and that's the same with language
learning so what i want to do is i want
to talk a bit like i have now been
active in turkish for two weeks two
weeks yesterday
and
i think that in those two weeks i have
learned quite a lot
certainly i have learned more than if i
had attended a university turkish class
for two weeks
you'll see with my statistics that i
have you know at least i can recognize
1300 words i i hear a lot of words that
i understand even when watching this
turkish soap opera on tv
so i've really kind of broken into the
language i know however that it's still
a long road for example if i pull
a an article from a newspaper into link
it's mostly blue words so there's a lot
for me yet to learn
i know that in the many stories that
i've been doing
there are a lot of words that i have
saved that are links i think there's
about 3000 of them i don't know them yet
so
there's a lot yet for me to do
but if i can keep a range of activities
in front of me
that i want to do
i'm motivated differently at different
times
but between the different things that i
do at link and being stimulated by
watching the turkish soap opera on
netflix
i remain active in the language
and that's the key to be active in the
language some people are very keen on
doing anki flash cards i'm not but if
that's what those people enjoy doing
then that's a good thing for them to do
because it keeps them active so the
breaking news is if you want to do well
in language learning stay active and now
i'll give you some specific examples of
the kinds of things that i do on link to
stay active and some of you say why do
you always talk about link the reason
there's two basically one i do my
language learning on link i enjoy it i
get excited about it and second of all
i'm a co-founder with my son mark of
link and we would like to encourage more
people to use link now
talk to you later
okay now let's look at the ways that i
stay active you have to stay active
you know if you want to get into
physical shape you have to stay active
you don't need to know how your muscles
work why certain exercises are good for
you you just have to do something you go
to the gym there's equipment there you
start using it
all right so
here is
how i stay active
on link other people may be active in
other ways
but i'm going to talk about what i do
so the first thing is
in order to stay active you have to keep
things interesting so i have spent a lot
of time on the many stories i'll move
myself over here for now i spent a lot
of time on the many stories in fact you
can see it here but i've also poked
around
outside the many stories in who is she
greetings and goodbyes and another thing
and ben saved him whatever that i can't
remember
uh i've poked around so who is she
you can see that i've actually created
305 links and who is she
i've poked around in greetings and
goodbyes
the advantage of the who is she is that
it's a dialogue whereas the mini stories
are not
unfortunately in turkish in both of
these it's one voice
i might actually have who has she done
again with a male and a female voice
however so the first thing is to keep
things
varied another thing
that helps my enthusiasm is this uh
turkish uh soap opera that my wife is
watching on netflix called yet gir ask
love is in the sky or something
and i pick up words here and there and
it's it's stimulating i don't i can't
understand what they're saying we have
english subtitles but it is part of
maintaining my motivation it's a form of
activity i'm not really learning but i
mean i'm encouraged and stimulated by
what i see
so also along the lines of being active
let's go into the many stories and i'll
show you some of the things that uh that
i do
come on now in loom where i'm filming
this sharing my screen with you
everything happens much more slowly than
in real life
but i wanted to show you
that
in the early stories for example which
i've listened to very often the number
of
words that i don't know in other words
links that i saved and now have
converted to known words is quite low so
i understand these stories quite well
wherever this number is low
pretty well i understand the story once
we get up to 24 words that i saved that
i'm hoping to learn but still haven't
learned the story's still a bit fuzzy uh
if i go
bear with me here if i go down to the
later stories
you know 43 words 54 53 74 59 so
obviously these are lessons that i have
a lot of trouble understanding and so
these are lessons that i have to keep on
going into
reading again typically i've listened to
the first stories 20 30 times i've read
them eight nine times whereas the later
stories i listened to twice and i've
read them twice so obviously i have to
get
you know active on those later stories
there's lots of time yet i've only been
in it for two weeks so i'll get there
speaking of which
um
just to have a quick look at my
profile
um
let's see is this gonna come up you know
what
i'll leave the profile for now
uh i wanted to show you something else
so
let's pick a story
so so i want to get into these stories
where i have a lot let's go story 30. i
don't know what's in there but that's a
toughy because story 29 i've got nine
links that i haven't yet converted but
in story 30 that must be a real tough
one because i got 50. so let's see what
we see in story 30.
and and this is somehow
one way that you can choose the next
lesson to study
is is to study something that you're
still struggling with so obviously i
have a lot of trouble
following this story and it has a lot of
words in it that i don't know
so as it's very slow to open up here in
loom
uh
again in terms of varying things i can
be in full text mode or i can be in
sentence mode
so and i can go to back to the beginning
here so now i'm doing it sentence by
sentence
so
one of the things that i find because
again you can vary it in terms of
plowing forward and and going into new
lessons with blue words and current
converting them to yellow
you can
[Music]
you know reread and simply read a lesson
that you're struggling with like this
one i could just read it again and in
reading in again i would probably
convert
some of the
uh you know yellow links into white
they're probably yellow links there that
i now know
so i can do that or i can delve more
deeply into the lesson and i'll show you
how i do that so
here for example i could look at the
translation
uh
so here again
this is supposed to show that the real
translation there is a bug right now and
it's showing the google translation but
the real translation has been pasted in
there
from the you know
real version of that story in whatever
your
uh native language is but
what i do is this because these are time
stamps
so i listen to it
and i go through it sentence by sentence
this helps a lot
um
with the lessons that are difficult
to
so one of the things i try to do is to
to imitate the pronunciation is a real
voice i imitate it and i focus on
intonation now
chemata secundary i now know that that's
mondays
green lady makes it plural
to martesi is monday so i might just say
okay i know that or monday it's saturday
saturday i got it wrong okay yes
zavatesy or something is monday i leave
it okay
but i have that phrase
uh
airken is early
i know that but calcare is to get up
but i really don't know that one so i
move on
a little bit
okay i struggled with that one but if i
keep on doing it i'm only going to get
better so that this is sort of something
that i find quite useful
so you're kind of delving more deeply
into the language trying to get a sense
of the pronunciation
and uh i find that that
that's very helpful even though i
stumble and mispronounce it doesn't
matter
doesn't matter
now if i look here at my
um
you know full text mode
i can go to
the uh you know
now
here again something that i can do
is in my uh let's move this guy down
here
in my review settings
uh
again pardon the slowness because of
loom
so i have set it up with just the
reverse flash card and dictation because
the flash cards are quite easy
multiple choice very easy i want to get
deeper into deeper into the language and
of course every time you do that you're
slowing yourself down in terms of your
sort of big picture reading and
listening activity you're now sort of
dealing with the nuts and bolts but i
find it useful to do that from time to
time
similarly we have uh
in the dictionary i'll show you that
later but so if i hear
we'll see how that goes no
so
so you have to get used to this this g
with a little
curly q on top that that's like a an
unpronounced so gidda jayi will go okay
i mean that just doing that helps me
let's do one more
okay now i've messed it up because i put
the
the uh answer right on the top of the
flash card so that's not so useful
market defined donation
okay this is i should have i should have
changed
okay
uh yeah let's i'll just show you that so
uh
in the um
review settings
uh
let's see here or maybe that's not where
you do it
and close that
in here maybe
okay auto grammar music barry somewhere
i'm allowed to determine what shows up
review settings that's strange
cards per session
somewhere maybe it's not showing up i'm
able to determine
uh what shows up on the face of the
flash card i'm not sure where that is i
won't bother with it no let's close that
so let's listen to this again
again
so that should be
now i would need to look at um
my
huh
i don't have oh well i guess that's how
you do it
let's close this
so this would be number two
girl i'm so used to on my girl dude
i think it was
good
[Music]
girl dude let's see what happens
a girl do okay so the dictation enables
you to sort of fine-tune your
listening ability and
uh you know i think both of these
exercises
uh that is to say uh you know listening
in sentence view
and um
dictation help you with your
pronunciation uh people particularly in
french they say i can't it just all
seems to flow together i can't tell what
people are saying and stuff so i would
suggest both of these activities
listening and repeating in sentence mode
where you have the natural voice and the
dictation as way as ways that you're
going to help your brain
you know define what it is you're
listening to um
and so i mean
that's enough one other thing i perhaps
could show you
in terms of an activity
and then i'll
i think you get the picture there's so
many different things that you can do
even though my main activity is
listening and reading at times i like to
focus in on on the nuts and bolts
first of all because it varies the
activity so that after a while i get
tired of reading rereading lessons and
listening for the third or fourth or
fifth time so here are some other things
that i can do that that helped me notice
so for example
if i go to the vocabulary section i can
choose phrases so i'm only going to be
looking at phrases
and maybe
uh i want to look at
you know phrases that come from a
particular
uh lesson
so i might go to sort of say the mini
stories
many
whoops
okay link many stories
and
[Music]
i want to go to story whatever i think
it was on story 30
so that uh
you know that's all i'm gonna look at
i have started tagging verbs i could
look for just verbs
and i apply that so i'm going to see all
of the
phrases that came out of this particular
lesson all of the phrases that i have uh
[Music]
linked
and i can quickly review them okay so
there's another it's just another form
of activity to ensure that you stay
active
and while i'm at it i can show you
my activity
is speaking of staying active for the
last two weeks
i have 1300 known words i have saved
3500 links
i have learned over a thousand links
the other words i picked up they were
either loan words from french or from
persian i've listened to almost 18 hours
i have read 51 000 words
so i have an activity score here a
composite activity score activity index
of 4 800 4874
the more active you are the better you
will learn it's a bit like working out
in the gym you have to be active
uh okay i think it's
that's enough for now
and i will now uh get back to talking to
you
i hope you were able to follow that
um
you know it's an experiment for me doing
these things in
on loom uh
the reaction on loom is a little slower
uh maybe i moved too quickly for people
so any comments about these
the way in which i show you the things
that i do on link please uh you know let
me know and if there are things that you
would like me to demonstrate also please
let me know
and for those of you who are not english
speakers remember you can
uh
import if you put on the closed captions
which have the english subtitles you can
import my videos into a link as a lesson
so that you can go over
the uh you know the
words that i'm using you can save them
you can learn them so
i think it's probably best for me to do
these videos in english so that
english native speakers will understand
them but also people who are learning
english can use them as lessons at link
in order to improve their english
so remember stay active bye for now
you